y'all know how to play Never Have I Ever
right yeah yeah but this is the drinking
version this is like the tell-all
version and you have to be honest if you
have you have to explain the story do we
have to be all deeper whatever you want
never have it ever somebody go never
ever deprived my body of something I
needed oh
[Music]
without sex the longest time you've been
like celibate oh man I've done it at
least a little bit over a year yeah 10
months almost a year 45 days this dog is
now 14 months I did a year and a half
five months because I was training yeah
that was it
the weirdest or the most unique place
I'm just gonna say driving down I-75
I-85 driving
how you doing driving Girl Gotta Get on
Top she sits on top to straddle
she got it she gotta sit there she got a
straddle you like this
she's here you can still see right oh
y'all people
doing it while you're driving is insane
I know I miss those areas never have I
ever had sex in a public bathroom
everybody's doing that I have not I
really haven't it's really disgusting
so uh airport we took the elevator down
a couple floors and ended up in the
Janitor's Closet I laid the garment bag
down and uh
I don't believe you haven't no I'm a bit
of approval to be honest really yes uh
Gondola top of a waterfall like uh we're
going snowboarding y'all did it in the
snow well yeah in the snow too yeah
I like it
is It's pretty dope there's a lot of
players oh
it was more there with them I am a
helpless romantic and so going to give
me a notebook oh my land it is
yeah all the people we met and talked to
I feel like I enjoyed Boston with him
teaching me how to wish I could mask
Travis Mack and Tyrone all in one I
would just take him I will put him in a
little box and I would just take off
running I wanted to see the writings on
the wall of his body
never have I ever
tossed somebody's salad oh was that a
statement or are you gonna tell us your
story
but I have done it yeah
[Music]
never have I ever heard so much weird in
my life you do have to be in a certain
position for that to happen no legs
I've had men men do like this like like
a strange
[Music]
the whole world don't need to know that
you out here licking men's booties but
women really enjoy that stuff okay